-Welcome, everybody.
Please, have a seat,
enjoy yourselves.
Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
This weekend, President Biden
went after big
social media platforms
like Facebook
for not doing enough to stop
the spread of COVID
misinformation.
Yeah, our country has gone from
the only thing we have to fear
is fear itself to please don't
take medical advice from a meme.
Seriously, you know,
there's a problem with Facebook
when you can find more
honest information on Tinder.
Yeah, Biden doesn't
want Facebook
to prevent young people
from getting vaccinated.
Everyone under 30 heard
were like, yeah, that's so cute,
but literally none of us
use Facebook, but they so...
Yeah, Biden and his
administration are busy,
in fact, they're now reversing
a Trump-era rule
that made showerheads
have more water flow.
In response, Trump spent the day
inciting a riot
in the plumbing section
of a Home Depot.
Speaking of Trump, check out
what the authors of a new book
said about the recent interview
with the former president.
At one point and the two
and a half hour sit down
with the book's authors
at Mar-a-Lago.
Mr. Trump suggested that
if George Washington
came back from the dead
and chose Abraham Lincoln
as his vice president,
it would have been very hard,
he says, for them to beat him.
If George Washington
came back from the dead
and chose Lincoln
as his running mate?
Does Trump think Abe Lincoln
still alive?
Well, guys, the Olympics are
almost here
and the athletes
in the Olympic Village
are sleeping on beds
made of cardboard,
and some people think
that they're meant to discourage
any intimacy.
That's nice, you finally reach
your Olympic dreams,
and had to sleep
on an Amazon box.
That's right, a bed designed
to discourage sex
or as that's also known
an air mattress.
That's right, because of COVID,
organizers want to make sure
every athlete is as celibate
as a badminton player.
Oh, we're going to get letters
from the badminton people.
Yeah, everyone's been
talking about this beds,
so a gymnast from Ireland,
put them to the test
in a viral video that he posted.
This is great. Check this out.
-The beds are meant
to be anti-sex.
They're made out of cardboard.
Yes, but apparently
they're meant to break
at any sudden movements.
It's big, big news.
-It works fine as long
as you have the body
of a 70-pound Irish gymnast.
So you're completely safe as
long as you have sex like this.
-Jumpin'.
-Here's some
good advice yesterday
during his weekly address,
Pope Francis urged people
to learn how to take a break
and turn off their phones.
Then the pope ended his address
by saying, that's my sermon.
Be sure to smash that
like button and subscribe.
Yeah, the pope said
to look closely
at the last supper and notice
how everyone left their phones
in a pile at the end
of the table.
Jesus is like Peter, Matthew,
give up the phone, please.
We're not going to do this
again, hence the title.
-Come on.
-What kind of supper
do you think this is?
So entertainment news
that I read,
the Paramount+ has ordered
a "Grease" prequel series.
Yep, the movie takes place
before the original "Grease,"
which means the actors
will only be about 48.
Can't believe
I'm in high school,
I got these high school
problems.
I think I'm going
through puberty, right.
Can't believe --
look at this new issue
of "AARP" magazine, right,
it's amazing.
You guys get your
Social Security checks?
This party's going to be
on point.
I love being in high school,
it's unbelievable.
Oh, my God. There's like
Werther's Originals everywhere.
It's amazing, right?
Hey, get this,
over the weekend,
there was a lot of debate online
about the lyrics to
Bruce Springsteen's song
"Thunder Road."
Some fans think he says
"Mary's dress sways,"
but the rest say
it's "Mary's dress waves."
But we actually have
someone on the phone
right now who can clear it up.
Bruce, are you there?
-Yeah. Hey, Jimmy.
-Thank you for being here.
Now, I don't know
if you've heard about this,
but people online were having
trouble understanding your song.
-Oh, I heard about that.
[ Mumbles indistinctly ]
-Right, right.
I imagine a lot of your fans
have been reaching out
and asking
if it's sways or waves.
-Right, it all sways and waves
and they do the swaying
and moaning with
the waverunners wave wave.
-Thank you so much for agreeing
to come on the show
and clear things up
once and for all.
Whenever you're ready,
go for it.
-Two, three.
[ Singing indistinctly ]
-Thank you so much
for clearing it up.
Bruce Springsteen, everybody.
-Yeah, bye, bye, Jimmy.
-It's sways. Yeah, sure.
Some business news
I saw that grocery stores
are now selling frozen
Chuck E. Cheese pizzas.
And this is fun.
The pizza is also being used
to make the cardboard beds
in the Olympic Village.
Isn't that amazing?
-Recycle.
-I read about a man in Florida
who was arrested
after crashing a stolen car
through an airport fence
and boarding
a Coast Guard plane.
I mean, I'm not surprised.
It happened in Florida.
I bet we can plug in any
three random words or phrases
and it would link to
an actual Florida news story.
Let's try it. It's time for
Florida news roulette.
Here we go.
-♪ Florida News Roulette ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
-Here's how it works.
The computer will generate
three random words
and we'll see if there's
a Florida news story
based on those words.
Let's get
our first three right now.
Candles, bear mace...
Candles, bear mace,
and Bath & Body Works.
Bear mace.
-Bear mace.
-What's the difference
between beer mace
and regular mace?
-About 350.
-Not sure how those can make
a news story,
but hey, in Florida, who knows?
Let's take a look.
-Oh, South Florida.
The search is on tonight
for a man who police say
used a bear mace
to steal candles
from Bath & Body Works.
-Wow.
All right, let's give it
another spin here.
Here we go, let's try.
Alligator, miniature golf,
cocktail lounge.
I couldn't even imagine
what this could be. Let's see.
-A Florida man is in jail
after a police officers
spotted him trying to throw
a live alligator
onto the roof of
a beachside cocktail lounge.
Police say the 32-year-old man
told officers
he stole the gator from its pen
at a miniature golf course
and was, quote,
"teaching it a lesson."
-That's right.
That's right, man.
Taught him a lesson.
Absolutely, showed him, man.
-I'll show you.
-He was teaching
the alligator a lesson.
-It was rude.
-That's right. Absolutely.
-I'm gonna throw you on top.
-He was trying.
-He was trying, yeah.
Alligator didn't learn
his lesson.
Let's try it one more time.
Here we go. One more time.
Everglades,
emergency landing, taco.
All right,
let's see what happened.
-A couple of guys had to make
an emergency landing
in their plane
in Collier County last week.
They survived and told officials
they were flying across
the Everglades on a taco run.
-You need some tacos.
And finally,
I saw that there is
a Swiss mountain for sale
on eBay for $235,000.
Sounds like a bargain,
but the shipping costs
are a fortune.
Hey, just so you guys know
why you were cheering,
three more billionaires
launched themselves into space.
Yeah, it was an exciting day
because just after 9:00
this morning,
Jeff Bezos flew to space aboard
Blue Origin's
New Shepherd rocket.
If you didn't see the launch,
here it is.
-Go, Jeff, go, Mark, go, Wally,
go, Oliver.
You are going to space.
-Yeah.
First, Branson, now Bezos,
and tomorrow, Warren Buffett
is going to try to get up there
with balloons
like the old guy from "Up."
That's right,
Bezos was launched into space,
which is the natural
career progression
for anyone who starts
an online bookstore.
Before his trip to space,
Bezos said
I'm just really excited
to figure out
how it's going to change me.
Well, here he is
before the flight.
And this is real.
Here he is after he landed.
-That's not real.
-I guess space turns you
into Kenny Chesney.
That's right, Bezos actually
wore a cowboy hat
for today's flight.
Can we see it again?
You know you're rich
when you put that on
and everyone who works
for you goes,
oh, it looks great, yeah.
You're a man of the people
just going to space.
Let me see it again. One more.
He looks like a mash up between
Buzz Lightyear and Woody.
You got the space suit
and cowboy hat together
by searching for the midlife
crisis bundle.
Is a soul patch too much?
Bezos wasn't alone.
He was joined by three
other people in the capsule.
Here's everyone together. Yep.
The first space crew to get
their portrait done at Walmart.
It looks like they're about
to do the 2:45 show
at the main pool at SeaWorld.
-[ Imitating seals ]
-Let's see it again?
Let me see it. There you go.
It looks like a portrait
of Mr. Clean's family.
The crew included
an 82-year-old pilot,
Wally Funk,
who became the oldest
astronaut in history,
and at one point you could
sort of tell.
Well, listen to this.
And she almost pushed
the launch button.
Like, no, Wally, no!
I feel like every zoom
with grandma.
It's like just push --
push on mute,
push on -- on, no,
that's your camera.
Just call grandma.
Well, a lot of people
were talking about
the shape of the rocket.
Can we see a photo of it?
It kind of looks like --
Well, I mean,
why would you design it
like that?
I just -- Anyway, let's just put
30 seconds on the clock
and see how many jokes
we can do here.
You want to get in on
this, Tariq?
-Oh, you know it.
-Alright, here we go.
It's the only rocket that
shrinks in the cold.
-They designed it at
the Johnson Space Center.
-It looks like R2-D2
took some Viagra.
-They don't keep it in a hangar.
They keep it in the top drawer
of a bedside table.
-Right after the launch,
the rocket goes into sleep mode.
-I'm surprised news channels
didn't have to blur that.
-Next stop, the "O"-zone.
-It's not that hard
to get to space.
-Well, it took a long time
to erect it.
-Guys, I got one.
-It looks like someone undid
their asteroid belt.
-I got one. I got one.
-What?
-It looks like male genitalia.
[ Ding ]
-Oh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow.
-Alright, changing gears.
Hey, this is fun.
I saw that Disney just unveiled
the first look at
Joe Biden's robot at
the Hall of Presidents.
-Ooh!
-Check this out.
-Oh.
-They can't seem to
master these, yeah?
He looks like
he opened the fridge
and can't decide what to eat.
"Activia.
Prunes. I don't know."
It's not great, but can we
take a look at Trump's?
Well, alright,
maybe Biden's isn't so bad.
Finally, on last night's episode
of "The Bachelorette,"
there was a pretty interesting
scene between Katie and Mike P.
We love "The Bachelorette"
here on the show.
But those scenes
can get pretty emotional.
So I thought that we could help.
Here's a clip from
the episode re-voiced
with the least-emotional person
we know -- Siri.
This is "Let's Get Siri-ous."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-[ Whispering ]
"Let's Get Siri-ous."
♪♪
-"She is a nurturer,
and, man, do I love nurturers.
She reminds me of my mom.
Your legs are soft."
"Oh, well, thank you. Ha ha."
My mom brings a nurturing touch
to everything
and every situation
that she comes in contact with.
Katie does the same thing."
You remind me of my mom."
-"Really?"
-I wanna say congrats
to the Milwaukee Bucks
for winning
their first NBA championship
in 50 years.
50 years.
That's right, they beat
the Phoenix Suns 105 to 98,
but of course, Arizona
has demanded a recount.
The finals MVP was
Giannis Antetokounmpo
who's from Greece.
Yep, Greek NBA superstar.
He could be the first person to
star in "Space Jam"
and "Mamma Mia!"
I love "Mamma Mia 2."
Is that my boyfriend?
Who? You mean, Fernando?
Just setting it up.
Last night's game was wild.
The Bucks had 65,000 fans
watching from outside the arena.
Look at this. Holy moly.
Yeah, it was all fun and games
until 65,000 fans
rushed to the one public
bathroom inside Starbucks.
Well, today, President Biden
traveled to Cincinnati, Ohio,
for a CNN town hall.
I'm not saying it was dull,
but they used it to disperse
all the Bucks fans in Milwaukee.
Speaking of the president,
a new poll found
that 66% of Americans
approve of Biden's
handling of the coronavirus.
The other 34% liked the way
things used to be back
when we had to Clorox
wipe our bananas.
Meanwhile, the Olympics
are just two days away,
and I saw that due
to COVID concerns,
the U.S. women's gymnastics team
has left the Olympic Village
to stay at a nearby hotel.
You know, there's a problem
when Red Roof Inn
is the safer option.
That's right,
the Olympics are almost here,
and I saw that every sport
has its own unique
logo designed for the games.
For example,
here's tennis, yeah,
well, it turns out while
these are the official logos
for Olympic events,
they're also the unofficial
logos for some other things.
I'll show you what I mean.
Here's another logo.
Officially, officially,
it's judo.
Unofficially,
it's shopping at TJ Maxx.
Here's another logo, officially,
it's wrestling, unofficially,
it's someone
who lost a contact lens.
And finally,
here's one last logo.
Officially,
it's canoe sprint.
Unofficially,
it's a guy who regrets
renting a stand-up paddleboard
on vacation like.
It looked cool in the picture.
Some entertainment news,
CNN just announced
that they're launching
their own streaming service
called CNN+.
Pretty sure there's already
a place to stream CNN 24 hours
a day, it's called CNN, right,
am I missing something?
Well, this isn't good, reports
of in-flight disturbances
are up 500% this year,
in-flight disturbances.
Now airlines are having to be
a little more aggressive
and they're even
adjusting their slogans.
Take a look
at American Airlines's
new slogan is,
"We duct taped a lady,
don't think
we won't do it again."
Oh, yeah, that's real.
Also, Delta's new slogan
is now offering
complimentary mouth guards.
I mean, that's...
-Wow.
And finally,
Frontier's new slogan is,
we can't afford
to press charges,
so do whatever, bro.
Go for it.
Well, get this,
Hidden Valley is now selling
a one and a half pound tub
of something called
pepperoni pizza dip.
Check it out. Here's a photo.
Proving once and for all that
some things from Hidden Valley
should probably remain hidden.
And finally,
today is National Hot Dog Day.
-Wow.
-How do I not lead with that?
Today is National Hot Dog Day
to celebrate,
Nathan's have five cent hotdogs
and for $1,
7-Eleven
sells something cooked
during the Obama administration.
That's right,
it's National Hot Dog Day.
So between that
and Jeff Bezos' rocket,
what a week it's been
for phallic-shaped objects.
Guess what's finally here.
The summer Olympics
kick off tomorrow.
This is a big deal.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The official motto
for this year's Olympics
is "United by Emotion."
Yeah, and
the unofficial motto is
"As of right now,
we're still doing it."
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Tomorrow's the big day,
and all of our best athletes
have arrived in Tokyo.
Legends like Simone Biles,
Katie Ledecky...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...Kevin Durant...
...and a dancing horse
named Butterscotch.
[ Cheers ]
Meanwhile, as if all the COVID
concerns around the Games
aren't bad enough,
a bear was spotted
inside the softball stadium
and is still on the loose.
What an Olympics
this is gonna be.
I mean, between the bears
and getting a disease,
it's like we sent our athletes
to a game of "Oregon Trail."
It's not a good situation.
Apparently, the bear got really
agitated after officials made
him sleep on a cardboard bed.
But officials are working hard
to make sure everyone stays safe
and healthy
at this year's Games.
But some people are still
unclear about what rules
the athletes have to follow
in Olympic Village.
So here to clear things up
is Olympics spokesman Ron Hobbs.
Ron?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ron, what is the IOC's
official policy
on getting together
and socializing in person?
-Jimmy, we'd never tell
these world-class competitors
what they can or can't do.
We're simply discouraging people
from engaging
in unnecessary physical contact.
-Right.
Maybe you could clarify
"unnecessary physical contact"?
-Simply put, no hanky-panky.
[ Laughter ]
No two-person push-ups.
No knocking boots.
No boffing, boinking,
buttering the biscuits,
boom-boom, bouncy-bouncy,
or bow-chicka-wow-wow.
-All right. Thank you.
Is that -- Is that why the beds
are made of cardboard?
-Actually,
the beds are just about
sustainability and recycling.
But if they happen to discourage
a game of human Tetris,
so be it.
Because there should be
no grown-up nap time,
no baking the potato,
no horizontal hula,
glazing the doughnut,
greasing the loaf pan,
or squat jumping
in the cucumber patch.
-All right. I...
I feel like
you're trying to say something
without really saying it.
And that's...
-Let me rephrase.
No tangling the downstairs
Christmas lights.
-Okay.
-No ordering fries "animal
style" from "In-N-Out Burger."
-What?
Maybe you should just tell us
the full list
of what's not allowed.
-Sure thing.
No rolling in the hay,
no digging up sand crabs,
no dipping the candle wick,
sweeping the chimney,
opening the Gates of Mordor,
letting the Joker
in the Batcave,
doing the Monster Mash,
rummaging in the root cellar,
searching for pocket change,
shocking the monkey,
shrimping the barbie,
shucking the oyster,
shellacking the canoe,
testing "the suspension,"
battering the corn dog,
getting busy, getting down,
getting it on,
getting some strange,
getting some
stank on the hang down,
doing "the nasty,"
"the wild thing,"
or doing the hoody-hoo!
♪♪
-Sorry. What I meant to say is,
what is allowed?
-Well, uh,
hand stuff is fine.
-Okay, thank you, Ron.
Ron Hobbs, everyone.
Thank you, very much.
Enjoy the Olympics.
-In-N-Out Burger.
-Well, that's not all
people are confused about
when it comes to the Olympics.
There's a lot
of misinformation out there,
so I thought it'd be helpful
to break down what's fact
and what's fiction
about this year's Games.
For example, Simone Biles
may attempt a Yurchenko
double pike vault
and half-on with two twists.
Fiction,
that's her Starbucks order.
-It's not true.
-Yeah, it's not true.
-Next up,
Facts -- karate, skateboarding,
sport climbing, and surfing,
are making their Olympic debut.
Fiction --
Frisbee golf is next, brah.
And finally, fact -- the Games
will have no spectators.
Fiction -- When they heard,
badminton players were like,
"Wait.
You can have spectators?"
That's fiction.
They know that.
Switching gears, last night,
Fox News aired a 10-second
public-service announcement
urging viewers
to get the vaccine.
Although it didn't help when
they ended the PSA by saying,
"Just so you know, this could be
the microchip talking."
[ Laughter ]
[ Scattered "Oohs" ]
Some tech news.
[ Chuckles ]
I saw that Amazon --
Amazon's Alexa just rolled out
a male voice assistant,
and his name is Ziggy.
Right now,
Jeff Bezos is thinking,
"I go to space for 11 minutes
and you name the voice Ziggy?
What's going on?"
Meanwhile, I heard that Twitter
is testing a new feature
that lets users
upvote and downvote tweets.
It's great.
It's like executives
looked at Twitter and thought,
"How can we make this place
even more toxic?"
"Your grandma's 90th birthday?"
Enh!
"No, thanks."
Well, this isn't good.
I read that muffins
sold at Walmart and 7-Eleven
have been recalled
over concerns about listeria.
Walmart apologized
while 7-Eleven just slapped on
a sticker that said
"Listeria flavored."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I'll take two of those."
And, finally,
this is going viral.
Teenagers in New Jersey
were celebrating a birthday
on one of those slingshot rides
at an amusement park
when something
unexpected happened.
Watch this.
-All right. Happy birthday.
-Bye!
[ Screaming ]
-What?!
-Wow!
That girl will now go
through her life with a phobia
of not just rides
but birthdays, in general,
I mean, that's one of
the scariest things --
Can we see that again?
That's insane.
[ Both screaming ]
Oh, my God!
Afterward, her friend was like
"Yeah, we're definitely gonna
buy the photo from that ride."
Well, guys, we are coming to you
after the Olympic
opening ceremony right now.
And a lot of people are talking
about Italy's outfits.
Take a -- Take a look at these.
Yeah.
Look like a bunch of Sbarro
workers going on strike.
Come on, Italy. You're in Japan,
the birth place of Nintendo.
How can you not bust out
the Mario and Luigi overalls?
I mean, come on.
But this isn't good --
an Australia equestrian athlete
was suspended
for a positive cocaine test.
Organizers knew something was up
when he jumped seven fences
during practice and --
and he wasn't on a horse.
Some sports news here in
the U.S. --
today, Cleveland announced
they're changing the name
of their baseball team to
the Cleveland Guardians.
Come on, even the name
Washington Football Team
is more exciting than that.
I'm surprised they didn't go
with something more unique
to Cleveland,
like The Layovers or...
We Miss Lebrons. You know?
People aren't wild about
their new logo either.
Here, look at the logo.
Oh.
Looks like Thor's helmet hooked
up with Mr. Mets.
So, this is big, too --
the NFL announced that
this season,
teams will automatically forfeit
games that are delayed
by a COVID outbreak.
Yup, the teams will have to
forfeit or worse,
change their names to
The Guardians.
Some business news -- I saw that
Walmart is offering
free health screenings to
customers starting tomorrow.
Meanwhile, one guy getting
his prostate checked
at Walmart today is like,
"What do you mean,
'starting tomorrow'?
Who are you?"
Yeah, I have cash.
And finally, I read about a mom
who threw her 6-year-old son
a Southwest Airlines-themed
birthday party.
His mom really nailed the theme,
because every kid went home
with four ounces of water
and a bag of old potato chips.